I was on a dating app for like 24 hours
then I left Camila Cabello reveals she
dipped her toe in the dating app pool
and took her toe right back out after
just one day I'm sorry I'm just so bored
of it the senorita singer stopped by the
Drew Barrymore show on Tuesday and
revealed the DM that made her say
bye-bye to online dating the first kind
of DMV was like aspiring
singer-songwriter from Nashville and I
was just like I feel weird because
somebody could be using me does that
make sense like you don't know their
intention yeah you don't know their
intentions but even that I'm like I
don't even know when you are just trying
to make friends you're gonna meet guys
that are vetted by your friends which is
amazing ironically Camila was most
recently linked to Austin kevich the
co-founder of lox Club a members only
dating app over the summer after A
source told ET at the time they were set
up by mutual friends
yeah really amazing the two first Spark
dating Rumors in June when they were
spotted out together and kept the
chatter going in August when they were
snapped on a stroll in La sharing a
couple of kisses on the cheek I'm really
happy and I feel really in touch with my
emotions which is which is good A source
told ET at the time that the two had
been seeing each other and dating quote
they're having a great time together and
really like each other they're both
funny and creative things are going well
it's just a bonus and it's incredible of
course this all comes after Camila and
Shawn Mendes called it quits in 2021
after more than two years of dating
those feelings are gonna come and I
think you just gather more and more
tools to cope with them in like healthy
ways
[Music]
yeah bomb bomb is Camilla's track
largely believed to be about her split
from Sean I said I love you for life but
I just sold the house
we were kids at the start I guess we're
grown-ups now and back in March Camila
opened up to ET about how her new music
was helping her navigate life after
heartbreak that's life you're on the
ground crying in the bathroom floor and
then you'll have feelings for another
person again and then you'll be crying
on the bathroom floor again and that is
kind of like the cycles of of change
like things just change you never know
what's around the corner
[Music]
thank you